quel est votre position aujourd'hui sur
le port de l'uniforme à l'école moi je
suis favorable à l'approche
expérimentation évaluation
j'étais plutôt favorable à l'approche
par établissement je constate qu'il y a
une telle pression sur ce sujet sur les
chefs d'établissement que expérimenter
évaluée permettra d'éclairer le débat
public donc à des expérimentations à
l'automne et on verra exactement ce que
donne c'est là qu'est-ce qu'on veut
faire à l'école je gère tout ça il faut
le remettre dans un contexte apaisé et
donc un on veut éviter les tenues qui
vous renvoie une religion parce que ça
vous exclut ça vous sépare et que ça ne
vous met pas dans un cadre commun et
c'est la laïcité 2 on vous éviter des
situations qui mettent un peu de la
stigmatisation sociale et donc moi on a
débat sur les marques mieux c'est trois
on veut éviter les tenues trop
excentriques qui qui provoquent